Speaker 1: I want to talk today about one tool
used by reactionaries to fool people and to goad
people into reactionary beliefs, and that is the
use of the fake or or imaginary slippery slope.
In general, reactionaries use fear as a tool.
They aggrandize threats beyond what they are to
make people afraid, and then they use that fear
to try to get people to support certain policies.
If you're really afraid of brown people from
Mexico coming to commit crimes and take your jobs,
you're likely to support extreme policies
on immigration. So the use of fear
and fearmongering by reactionaries is very
common. One example of the false slippery
slope and a slippery slope is saying, Well, if we
do a, it's definitively going to lead to B, C, D,
e f, etc. When sometimes a will just be a an.
A great example we have because of the pandemic
is the fake slippery slope of vaccine
mandates. As you may know, for over a year now,
the reactionary right has been saying the first
thing is you've got to get a COVID vaccine
and the next thing you know, ABCD EFG.
And we now have over 200 years of history
to tell us that vaccine mandates don't lend
themselves to more authoritarianism. And you just
look at the history. And 1777 George Washington
required the smallpox vaccine for all soldiers.
And then, you know, 30 years went by, and in
18 09, Massachusetts put in its first vaccine
mandate. And then another 40 years went by and
then in 1855, a Massachusetts, Massachusetts
instituted vaccine requirements for schools. And
then in 1985, in the U.S. Supreme Court case,
Jacobson v. Massachusetts, the Supreme Court
said now municipalities can. This can can put in
a vaccine mandate. And people were saying, this is
the start of what? And it just never went further.
In 1977, we had the childhood immunization
initiative start, and it's just about getting
kids vaccinated. And more recently, people with
the COVID vaccine saying this is the start of a
dystopian authority now. And in fact, many places
have already removed vaccine mandates for travel.
Employers are removing vaccine mandates as the
pandemic wanes, and so it's an obviously false
slippery slope. The vaccine mandates over the last
200 years have not led to anything more than that.
You can really tell the difference in how the
right uses slippery slopes and fearmongering
by thinking about something like health
care. I mean, look, I just think it through.
We on the left say about health care. Listen, the
right wants this like total for profit free market
health care thing. They generally speaking, want
to let insurance companies charge whatever they
want to. People with preexisting conditions deny
them insurance. And if the right got its way,
we would continue to see medical bankruptcies,
which we're already seeing. We would continue
to see people unable to afford or access care,
which we already see. All of this stuff exists
right now. There's no crazy fear mongering
from the left on health insurance, the right
says. If the left gets his way gets its way. It's
the start of a communist takeover of health care,
where government bureaucrats will create death
panels and decide whether you live or die.
And it will be the start of a government takeover
of every industry. What so you see how one side
does the slippery slope, reactionary fear
mongering? And we say we're going to continue
seeing the same problems. If we don't, if we don't
fix this very different language that's used.
So the best thing when you start hearing these
slippery slope claims, if you do this, it's going
to lead to all this other stuff. First of all, ask
for examples of when that has happened, that one
tool that you can use. Secondly, ask the person
claiming the slippery slope will happen to explain
exactly how. Because if you actually say to
people, well, hold on. How will a vaccine mandate
on COVID vaccines lead to whatever it is you're
afraid of? Like exactly what are the steps and
who will enact it? And it's also a good tool to
show the disconnect between the different pieces
of this slippery slope. Often, they won't even
explain the path down the slope. When they do,
it often makes no sense whatsoever. So those are
some tools that you can use. But whenever you're
presented with a slippery slope, ask yourselves
those questions. Is there historical evidence
that that's what would actually happen? How would
it happen? And does that actually make any sense?